In the summer of 1982, a 33-year old unemployed
royal fanatic twice scaled a 14-foot wall
topped with barbed wire and revolving spikes,
shimmied up a drainpipe, entered Buckingham
Palace through unlocked windows, sat on the
Queen’s throne and even enjoyed a brief
tête-à-tête with Her Majesty.
Michael Fagan was born on August 8, 1948 in
London.
Married in 1972, at the time he broke into
the Palace, Michael had four children ages
3 to 10.
Although previously having worked as a decorator
and painter, Michael was out of work when
he began planning his break-ins.
Telling his mother that he was visiting his
“girlfriend – Elizabeth Regina,” Fagan
made 12 trips to the Palace in the months
before his eventual intrusion.
For his first break-in, in June of 1982, Fagan
claimed he had entered the Palace through
the window of a maid’s room; and, although
she immediately reported the break-in, when
security personnel were unable to find him,
they assumed she imagined it.
Fagan then says he spent the rest of that
evening exploring the Queen’s home, finding
the rooms of both Prince Charles and Princess
Diana.
There for awhile and unable to locate a water
closet, Fagan claims he peed in the corgi
food.
He also says he drunk some wine he found in
Prince Charles’ room.
Feeling like, in his words, Goldilocks, Fagan
also took turns sitting on several thrones.
Although he claims it was harder getting out
than in, Fagan said he eventually left through
the back gardens and, once again, simply climbed
over a wall.
The day after the first intrusion, Fagan tried
to steal a car and was imprisoned for three
weeks before being released on bail.
He entered the Palace for the second time
the next day.
Beginning at about 7:00 a.m., Fagan once again
scaled the wall and climbed up a drainpipe,
this time to the roof of the Palace where
he left his sandals and socks.
He shimmied across a narrow ledge and entered
the building through another unlocked window.
Fagan then, in his words, “follow[ed] the
pictures,” to determine which apartments
were the Queen’s.
During this time, Fagan set off at least one
alarm, which was ignored; it was later determined
that several other alarms had been improperly
installed.
In any event, at about 7:15 a.m., he broke
a glass ashtray and then carried one of the
shards with him into the Queen’s bedroom
where “he intended to slash his wrists in
the presence of Her Majesty.”
After he opened the curtains near her bed,
Queen Elizabeth pressed the night alarm, but
due several coincidences, no one was there
to hear, or respond to, it: the night watchman
had already gone home, and the domestic help
that normally would have been in the pantry
to hear the alarm were cleaning another room
and walking the dogs, respectively.
Fagan claims that the Queen was wearing a
knee-length Liberty print nightie when she
exclaimed, “Wawrt are you doing here?!”
She then telephoned for help at about 7:18
a.m., but assistance was late in arriving,
so the Queen, with the assistance of a maid,
coerced Fagan into a pantry by saying he could
find a cigarette there.
Finally locating a footman, the Queen and
the maid left him in charge of Fagan; the
footman not only supplied Fagan with cigarettes,
but, at least according to Fagan, also gave
him a glass of the Queen’s Famous Grouse
whiskey that she kept on hand.
According to the official report, the Queen
remained on the scene but was occupied with
keeping her corgis away from Fagan, who was
becoming increasingly agitated.
Fagan later claimed that his brief foray into
breaking and entering was the result of taking
too many “magic mushrooms,” from which
he was still high.
In the end, Fagan wasn’t charged for the
break-ins, although he spent time in mental
institution for psychiatric evaluation in
1982.
After the break-in, Fagan continued to get
into trouble with authorities, including assaulting
a police officer and dealing heroin.
In 1987, he was charged with indecent exposure,
although, according to Fagan, he had simply
removed his pants when he dove into the water
to retrieve some tackle (he had been fishing,
and smoking pot, with some friends).
Although the in-court testimony from the female
witness was that he had “a huge erection,”
Fagan challenged this, noting “‘her husband
must be like that’ . . . measuring a tiny
distance with his thumb and forefinger.”